hello and welcome to this video playing
Massoud one three five one J okay let's
see
there should be close to my all-time
high rating and something I should check
later I have a really good run there on
leeches I think I have won the last 15
games something like that okay so this
is a super sharp line that is not great
for black but it's the kind of thing
that you can easily forget yeah how it
works especially after Knight takes
before you're here um why should be a
little bit better d5
really okay I'll take here
yeah I should probably take on one six
and now he will take with the pawn there
is no good intermediate move so it's a
it's a five right here or I mean the
pawn is hanging he 594 we should be true
it's got Bishop f5 then yam that is in
fact that is a bit annoying
it isn't sexually interesting I mean
black has got very very quick
development so it's not it's not
completely silly position for black so
yeah I want to get out of the middle
yeah quickly there should be two I guess
and then castles I need a bit of time
here if I get a bit of time
my position is okay at least okay Bishop
a6 coming so yeah our castle
Bishop a6 and where where to go we had
to go we should be too that's always 92
I wonder if after Bishop takes c3 like I
move the Queen to let's say H 3 and he
takes on c3 if I can interpose Bishop a
6 Bishop a 6 now you can take on B to
win
okay
I still probably should have gone to f3
huh well anyway it's not it's not
should've gone to three eyes got 94 now
and then I'd rather want to be on f3
then on d1 yeah anyway okay so over here
I wonder if 96 to see who is the right
plenty of him preventing I'm preventing
the pawn from moving I think I'm playing
it I mean I would like to develop my
Bishop but that is nothing too important
to not play at her make sure I get rid
of the double pawn yeah that's more
important
okay now time to develop just wonder
Wham
but should be a form maybe there's Queen
to f6 should be three our evidence 96
Bishop f4 Queen f6 is quite quite
annoying Bishop e3 is the alternative
but you can take and that's 92 then what
about this one
yeah yeah and then I have C for a second
time later you know f3 now yeah yeah
please go back
yeah okay now that is I'm starting to
get a grip on this position now his
night now does not really do all that
much
yeah night wants to come to his success
for sure yeah maybe maybe maybe and
should have done that differently
I'm still not overly concerned the night
comes to e6 here should have played a
bit quicker that would have been a good
idea or a bit more quickly is that right
that's better grammar and still that so
will be fair a fair amount of work I
need to push this back
when blundering the the dem home ah and
that was bad
that was really bad I'm losing this game
wow that is bad from a completely
winning position I mean there was
absolutely nothing that he could do and
I managed to screw it up
Wow not easy poor yeah what is that
hashtag yeah you always say hashtag
nowadays first I know game before
breakfast yeah is the hashtag for that
one okay I have an a pawn but he's got a
million extra points a million young
and it's so easy to play g4 g3 is just
over that is also lost its annoying
really the game that was basically lost
from the very Oh from the opening stage
you shouldn't really lose I don't want
to resign already because he played it
so badly we can always hope but it's
impossible to screw up it's a problem at
unfortunately I mean he plays it in the
worst possible way but it is still
unfortunately completely lost
and maybe I should resign but I don't
want to end my streak oh it's so painful
with that game oh my god
yeah around here is just completely done
but you know I managed to somehow - so
uh screw that up
I let the clock run down a bit too much
yeah if three years kind of a good
routine move in a way but now now I'm
doing this really badly I mean Quincy
323 is really bad I was panicking a
little bit you know yeah rookie seven
it's not such an easy move to play when
you have absolutely no time but what I
want what i really i sometimes have this
tendency when I'm when I've screwed it
up a little bit and I know I have no
time I tend to go for Queen trade simply
to and to make it simpler in a way to
play a Queen III is of course atrocious
after that it gets very easy for him to
play please stop sending me stuff for
whatever reason um yeah the Queen d3 is
terrible I mean it's clear that
basically a man if you don't blunder
this you're winning I even chief always
probably winning and that's not a good
move
you know so that's this opening is a
little bit on there with d5 but it felt
that was quite interesting so take take
the engine actually wants to play this I
hide away a little bit because 94
there should be two and I was thinking
yeah Bishop f5 is another tempo but in
fact it's not a big deal Bishop f5 I
can't go here you know it probably means
that if I have a stronger own 95 is good
for black you now he's got good too man
so he's got good development there's
absolutely no doubt there so if five is
better okay yeah I was I was it was not
not well judged so even this is good
he has good development has absolutely
no no question but maybe it's it's a
case when this has no squares yeah like
if I do this and have three it's trapped
was some other Queen move well there's
not many there not many other Queen was
hmm I was a little bit concerned but
that seems to be better and yeah even
here he had compensation I think and
Knight takes seems to be just just
better for for black yeah I was thinking
we should be to what ah Wow Wow okay so
that that is the thing it can take and
Bishop a six and that's terrible
that's bad yeah the engine gives me four
inaccuracies 11 mistakes and two
blunders here if you if you get this
kind of statistic and you know it's on
an engine
oh my god yeah and night takes was a lot
stronger than and he I'm starting to at
least be okay even though he definitely
has compensation he should call 96 in
this position and he didn't do that I
think okay I have this actually for a
pin so that's important he doesn't get
to see for it's still probably better
than allowing see for the moment I got
this end the position is like in a
tournament game in a classical time
control game that's a winning position
what should witness because the night
will never get to good square the best
possible square c6 and then you still
can cover it easily and the a pawn is
terminally weak in any any ending so
it's it's easy but I managed to screw it
up okay guys thanks for watching